thierry tu en as choisi trois jours me
elles vont apparaître de l'autre côté
maintenant je vais te dis a demandé de
te mettre en place là-bas et c'est parti
et tu va choisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois tendances merci est ce qu'elles
sont là les cherry est ce qu'elles sont
là les sk sont la mairie chéri
jean-michel ne les voit pas à hawaï
bonsoir en effet bonsoir chômeurs pour
soir
[Applaudissements]
attention il ne reste plus que trois y a
plus jamais nous sommes et elouan quoi
mais j'adore mais je pense avoir battu
l'a éliminée au look quoi alors jeanne
il va revenir avec notre public parce
qu'on aime mon chéri elle se lève
attention tu as pourra poser une
question à chacune des trois jeunes
filles et tu en éliminera une après
phase alors je n'ai pas le numéro un jeu
s'appelle comment alors abattu la pause
est d'abord une question à summer tu
vois là vous y voyez soir c'est mal ça
c'est bon c'est bon alors là oui on
t'attend connard alors là s'appelle
comment sa mère
sammer je suis je te propose de passer
deux semaines de vacances dans un
camping naturiste est ce que tu veux ça
te branche ou est ce que ça te dégoûte
alors pour toi je ferai peut-être un
effort mais j'avoue que j'ai pas de
problème avec la nudité donc aujourd'hui
oui côté lui oui mais ça envoie la
réponse à sa part bien alors allez-y
maintenant je vais cette maison a poli
dans les bd plus à l'est pauline comme
tu le sais quand on est chroniqueur atp
mp on est forcément un peu connues est
ce que la notoriété de te gêne non non
pas du tout je pense que c'est quelque
chose auquel on peut faire abstraction
et essai mais malgré tout n'était pas
trop jalouse de ses impôts que ça
calcule non je suis pas jaloux je suis
plutôt très supportrice en fait ça forge
est vraiment la personne avec 8 ou
plutôt de la jalousie non ça m'en tire
un peu aussi du bolliger bien sûr que
non non non d'accord une question
animale tu dois partir sur une île
déserte avec seulement trois objets
lesquels est-ce que tu prends avec toi
lesquels pointu avec toi à un objet oui
obligé ça sera un sex toys france donc
trois sextoys donc bah oui quand même
à droite
je déserte après servir si on n'a pas de
lumière un truc comme ça
le poids mais bercy mais trois objets
donc des trois objets ça sera un texte
un sex toys mais l'oreille ça sera trop
d'accord très bien alors attention
jean michel tu peux en d'éliminer une
tout de suite elles sont quand même très
très bien
oui j'en ai mis tout de suite là oui bah
oui une des trois jeux éliminé
pauline pauline bâché pas ces bolides
malheureusement jean michel ne vous a
pas retenu pauline polyphonie la tuauru
flers je montrais jean-louis vous êtes
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
c'est par jean-michel oui pourquoi autre
monde non c'est vraiment le charme de la
gela la drôle enfin je suis très très
réceptive à 60 millions d'urbains vous
êtes bien la seule mère pauline mais
dont les flux réfléchir estime anne et
reste seulement les filles vous allez
nous a posé une question à jean michel
et il en choisira une à leslie se meurt
alors jean-michel étude du genre
dominateur ou soumis ce vous avez pas d
kitsch au genre tels dernier bouquin
délire comme ça en fait c'est assez
curieux les questions c'est alors donc
je le dernier bouquin que j'eus et je
suis dominant est alors d'accord du col
merci et man moi je voudrais savoir à
jean michel c'est quoi le plus important
pour toi dans un couple le fait des
fautes et comment les sexes finale aller
et venir à sa tête michel c'est quoi le
plus important pour toi dans un couple à
90%
c'est le sexe la fidélité la beauté
selon elle va trouver
voilà c'est à toi de me dire c'est quoi
de plus important dans les trois à
l'agent me l'esprit famille à la famille
adacore 6 actuellement et se passe rien
bah pas non plus exagérer
d'accord d'accord mais ça vous va comme
réponse ben ça vous va pas trop d'accord
jean michel est ce que tu as fait ton
choix je penserai d'aller dîner avec
elle ce soir j'ai envie tu choisis qui
s'amarrent
sachez que summer on a caché son nom
parce que l a déjà fait d'émissions de
téléréalité part active oups on m'a dit
disposé à l'oreille et donc c'est pas
son vrai nom donc on s'est dit si pour
pas pour pas l'influencé s'est pas fait
entrer l'accusé quand même iman jean
michel a choisi sonore d'aller poids
alors vous allez voir à côté jean-michel
malheureusement iman
iman est éliminé servira peut-être quand
même assez bon merci merci va d'abord
être à simone par la part là-bas
cherrypal voilà merci summer levé vous
le rideau va tomber on a ils ont répété
ça y paraît tout l'après midi
quand j'allais voir jean-michel enfin
vous l'avez déjà vu vous le connaissez
vous et il va vous découvrir jean michel
et se meurt et ce soir vous allez
dîner ensemble 3 2 à 1
comment ça
ba se meurt
messieurs le savez vous irez dîné
ensemble ce soir vous allez attendre
janvier generation
vous êtes content très contente c'est un
oui et bien mais si summer est vraiment
intéressé par jean-michel arrive
vraiment si vous la met pas son avocat
la balle je suis plutôt cougar mais
j'adore mon charme
c'est là quelque chose c'est en tout cas
parce que voilà et vous aimez vous
voulez faire une histoire avec lui est
ce que c'est mais bon il est temps
d'avoir du sérieux vous avez vous avez
34 ans très bien et bien ce soir vous
avez dit non sens mieux maintenant et
non non non la vous restez vous faites
les missions et bien sûr ou débriefera
lundi et qui paye 1 c'est vous merci
c'est tout sinon c'est pas mal c'est
pour moi merci
par contre c'est pas loin et pas cher
il est il et il est de plus en plus
lourds 1ère rien à dire un non mais
c'est la merde tout cas bravo un sans
faute ou sept comptant pas moins très
bas vous allez faire la connaissance de
summer ce soir voilà vosges oreilles
tous les autres numéros quoi balada
c'est fini tous les lots de numéros
c'est fini et vous aurez une prétendante
qui se présentera ça sera la prétendante
de valérie benaïm lundi je vous dis oui
mais si ça fonctionne avec celle ci a
bah si ça fonctionne lui dit je veux
plus voir personne
voilà non je vois des gens je vous
rapatriez
[Applaudissements]